بس خلينا نروح لمصر شويه سالنا الناس هل
ترون ان الملل قد يكون مفيدا بعض الشيء
[موسيقى]
المال ممكن بيودي كلاب وفي واحد ثاني لعلي
ممكن يوديه لسكه غلط او افكار جنونيه
افكار شيطانيه الكلام ده كله على حسب
العقل في الاول وفي الاخر يعني بعد لما
يكون قاعد لوحده بتحس ان فيه كده
فاهم اللي هو حاجات بتطلع مره واحده وانت
قاعد لوحدك رسمي مثلا اغاني تقريبا برده
طول الوقت فاضي همم دي حاجه بتساعدني برده
انا اكتشفت حاجات كثير بسبب ال ملل او
الفضه ممكن الواحد يكون عنده موهبه الرسم
فيطلع الملل بتاعه دوت في الرسم يطلع اي
حاجه في الرسم بس مش برده مش في كل
الاوقات يعني الناس ممكن يخليني مثلا افكر
في اللي انا باعمله ازاي مختلفه او كده
ولكن مثلا لو حاجه انا اصلا ما بحبهاش من
الاول او يعني
مثلا واحد بيغني دلوقت خليك انا قاعد
زهقان قال لك لما يفكر يجرب يعمل كده اي
حاجه كده اصلا
[موسيقى]